in a previous video we used a proof by
contradiction to show that the square
root of 2 is irrational what i want to
do in this video is essentially use the
same argument but do it in a more
general way to show that the square root
of any prime number is irrational so
let's assume that p is prime
p is prime
and we're going to set this up to be a
proof by contradiction so we're going to
assume that the square root
square root of p
is rational and see if this leads us to
any contradiction
so if something is rational if something
is rational that means that we can
represent it as a ratio of two integers
and if we can represent something as the
ratio of two integers that means that we
can also represent it as a ratio of two
co-prime integers or two integers that
have no factors in common or that we can
represent it as a fraction that is
irreducible as a fraction that is
irreducible so i'm assuming that a this
fraction that i'm writing right over
here a over b that this right over here
is an irreducible fraction you say well
how can i do that well
this being rational says i can represent
square root of p as some fraction as
some ratio of two integers and if i can
represent anything as a ratio of two
integers i can keep dividing both the
numerator and the denominator by the
common factors until i eventually get to
an irreducible
an irreducible fraction so i'm assuming
that's where we are right here so this
this cannot be reduced and this is
important for our proof
cannot be reduced which is another way
of saying that a and b are co-prime
which is another way of saying that a
and b share no common factors other than
one
so let's see if we can manipulate this a
little bit let's take the square of both
sides we get p
is equal to
well a over b the whole thing squared
that's the same thing as a squared over
b squared
a squared over b squared we can multiply
both sides by b squared and we get b
squared times p
is equal to a squared
is equal to a squared well what does
this tell us about a squared
well b is an integer so b squared must
be an integer so an integer times p is
equal to a squared well that means that
p
must be a factor of a squared so let me
write this down so a squared
a squared
is a multiple
multiple
of
a squared is a multiple of p
now what does that tell us about a does
that tell us that a must also be a
multiple of p
well to think about that let's think
about the prime factorization of a
let's say that a can be re and any
number can be written as a product of
primes or any integer i should say so
let's let's write this out as a product
of primes right over here so let's say
that i have my first prime factor times
my second prime factor all the way to my
nth prime factor i don't know whether
how many prime factors a actually has
i'm just saying that a is some integer
right over here
so that's the prime factorization of a
what is the prime factorization of a
squared going to be well a squared is
just a times a its prime factorization
is going to be f1 times f2 all the way
to fn
and then that times f1
times f2 times all the way to fn or i
could rearrange them if i want f1 times
f1
times f2 times f2 all the way to fn
times fn
now we know that a squared is a multiple
of p p is a prime number so p must be
one of these one of these numbers in the
prime factorization p could be f2 or p
could be f1 but p needs to be one of
these numbers in the prime factorization
so p
p needs to be one of these factors well
if it's let's say and i'll just pick one
of these arbitrarily let's say that p
is f2
if p is f2 then that means that p is
also a factor of a
so this allows us to do this allows us
to deduce that a
this allows us to deduce that a
is a multiple
a is a multiple
of p
or another way of saying that is that we
can represent a
we can represent a as being some integer
times p
times some integer
some integer times p
now why is that interesting and actually
i'm going to let me box this off because
we're going to reuse this part later
but how can we use this well just like
we did in the proof of the square root
of the square of 2 being irrational
let's now substitute this back into this
orig this equation right over here so we
get b squared times p
we have b
squared times p
times p
is equal to a squared well a we're now
saying we can represent that as some
integer k times b
so we can rewrite that as
we could rewrite that as some integer
write it with this
sum integer k
times p
times
p
and so let's see if we were to multiply
this out so we get b squared times p
and you probably see where this is going
is equal to k squared
k squared times p squared
times p squared we could divide both
sides by p
and we get
we get b squared is equal to p times k
squared is e or k squared times p
k squared times p
well the same argument that we used if b
squared times p
is
if a squared is equal to b squared times
p that let us know that a squared is a
multiple of p so now we have it the
other way around b squared is equal to
some integer
squared which is still going to be an
integer times p so b squared must be a
multiple of p
so this lets us know
that v squared is multiple
is a multiple
of p
of p and by the logic that we applied
right over here that lets us know that b
is a multiple of p
v
is multiple
of p and that's our contradiction or
this establishes our contradiction
that we
assumed at the beginning
we assumed that a and b are co-prime
that they share no factors in common
other than one we assumed that this
cannot be reduced but we've just
established just from this we have
deduced that a is a multiple of p and b
is a multiple of p which means that this
fraction can be reduced we can divide
the denom the numerator and the
denominator by p so that is our
contradiction we started assuming it
cannot be reduced but then we show that
no it must be able to be reduced the
numerator and the denominator have a
common factor of p
so
our contradiction is established p
squared of p cannot be rational square
root of p is irrational let me just
write it down square root of p
is
irrational
is irrational because
of the contradiction